[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
ya estaba lista en el estudio daniel
hablando onda ni bienvenida a feliz
mañana de martes le pregunto cómo está
la economía afgana seis meses después de
que ellos asumieran el control habló de
los talibanes
raúl muy buenos días buenos y fríos días
y totalmente en poco está helada pues
mire afganistán ha experimentado una
dramática transformación durante seis
meses de dominio talibán
anteriormente de este país asiático se
financiaba en un 80 por ciento de ayuda
internacional y ahora que no la tiene de
naciones unidas se estiman que unos 23
millones de personas que es más de la
mitad de la población necesitan
asistencia humanitaria hay una
percepción generalizada raúl de que el
país es menos violento de lo que fue
antes evidentemente pero la economía se
está precipitando al colapso y es que
antes de que los talibanes se hicieran
con el poder el banco central afgano
había depositado en el extranjero unos 9
mil millones de dólares y esos fondos
permanecen bloqueados 7 mil millones
están en eeuu que ya dijo que iba a
repartir la mitad entre los familiares
de las víctimas del atentado del 11 de
septiembre esto es calificado como un
robo por parte de los actuales líderes
afganos ahora hablemos de los ciudadanos
como ellos sienten todos estos cambios
económicos pues raúl a diferencia de
cuando gobernaron por primera vez en
2000 en la década del 90 ahora se está
permitiendo por parte de los talibanes
que algunas mujeres trabajen por ejemplo
sin embargo el desempleo ha aumentado y
son justamente ellas las más afectadas
los precios han aumentado la moneda
local se desplomó y los bancos se
quedaron sin efectivo a veces los
residentes tienen que esperar horas e
incluso días para retirar un límite de
200 dólares semanales de sus propios
ahorros inclusive raúl es la situación
es tal que ha hecho que aumenten las
tarifas que cobran en el mercado ilegal
a quienes quieren emigrar hacia otros
países
danny bueno lamentable la situación de
afganistán sobre todo los ciudadanos
vamos ahora a poner en la mesa otro tema
auditores ponen en tela de juicio los
estados financieros del ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump porque
daniela de la firma auditora de la
organización trump que es la del ex
presidente de eeuu se desvinculó de la
empresa pero no sin antes poner la lupa
sobre los informes financieros y
restarles también credibilidad se trata
de la empresa mason es que reveló que ya
no podía garantizar que fueran correctas
las cuentas que había preparado para la
empresa del ex presidente entre 2011 y
2020 formuladas con datos que entregaba
la misma organización la justicia en
nueva york' está adelantando
investigaciones tanto civiles como
criminales pues sospecha que la
organización trump ha inflado el valor
de sus activos para conseguir más
préstamos financieros y también para
pagar menos impuestos se imagina una
semana laboral de cuatro días si yo me
la imagino todo también me lo imagino
pero no sé si lo lleguemos a saborear
digamos pero en europa sí porque hay
unos ciudadanos de un país de ese
continente que lo pueden hacer de que
estamos hablando de raúl el de bélgica
pues allí el gobierno llegó a un acuerdo
para permitir esto reformar el mercado
laboral
y permitir que las personas trabajen
solamente cuatro días como ya lo hizo
recordar a usted emiratos ahora si el
año pasado esto va a permitir dos cosas
primero concentrar la semana de trabajo
en cuatro días y flexibilizar los
horarios para darles más libertad a los
trabajadores y que podrán disfrutar del
quinto día libre también podrán optar
por un régimen semanal variable qué
quiere decir trabajar más horas en una
semana y tener más horas libres la
siguiente semana danny y entonces le
pregunto qué otras medidas va a incluir
esta reforma bueno por ejemplo reforzar
el derecho a la formación proteger mejor
a los empleados de plataformas digitales
como uber entre muchas otras y otro
aspecto bien interesante y también se
está evaluando en varios países y es la
extensión del derecho a la desconexión
fuera del horario laboral es decir que
los empleados no tendrán presión por
responder a mensajes o correos
electrónicos en este lapso el objetivo
de todas maneras es que para 2023 el 80
por ciento de la población esté empleada
en este país bueno vamos a ver entonces
qué pasa con eso danny y vamos a hablar
de los indicadores
los mercados siguen por supuesto muy
pendientes de las noticias que les
lleguen sobre ucrania aunque las bolsas
europeas se recuperan a esta hora pues
de parte de las ganancias de las
pérdidas que tuvieron en la jornada
anterior a medida que se va suavizando
el discurso en rusia y en eeuu en asia
se observó una tendencia contraria tokio
bajó tras conocerse que el crecimiento
económico japonés fue de apenas 17 por
ciento en 2021 para finalizar que nos
trae como cifra el día vamos a continuar
en rusia y en ucrania porque las cifras
unos diez mil millones de dólares en
garantías de préstamo que ofreció eeuu a
ucrania en medio de la crisis con rusia
quiere decir no que le vaya a prestar
sino que va a garantizar bueno vamos a
ver entonces qué pasa también con eso
han y gracias por toda la información
hemos más adelante y con más economía en
directo américa pasamos a ver ahora
nuestro reportaje